[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen in der Stadt
des Westfälischen Friedens müssen sie
wieder über den Krieg reden
g7-treffen der außenministerinnen und
Minister im historischen Rathaus zu
Münster damals hatte es fünf Jahre
gedauert bis
1648 der 30-jährige Krieg in Europa
beendet war die Bedingungen bei den
Verhandlungen in Münster und Osnabrück
waren kompliziert es gab keinen
Waffenstillstand es gab keine
international anerkannten Regeln der Weg
zum Westfälischen Frieden war deshalb
auch einer zu einer europäischen
Friedensordnung und zum heutigen
Völkerrecht
jetzt ist wieder Krieg in Europa und
Frieden scheint in weiter Ferne viel zu
besprechen für die Chef Diplomaten der
sieben wirtschaftsstärksten Demokratien
dieser Welt Andreas Kühnast beobachtet
das für uns
es ist kein leichter Tag zum
Demonstrieren aber der bisher beste um
es zu versuchen sie sind aus Kiel aus
karkif aus operoshia geflohen nach
Münster Westfalen wo plötzlich für 26
kurze Stunden die ganze Macht der halben
Welt ist und die Chance dass man sie
hört
wir wissen dass sich viele wünschen dass
wir Ukrainer Verhandlungen anbieten aber
wenn Russland aufhört zu kämpfen gibt es
keinen Krieg mehr wenn die Ukraine
aufhört zu kämpfen gibt es keine Ukraine
mehr
so oft wie noch nie neunmal haben sich
die G7 Außenminister bereits getroffen
in diesem schlimmen Jahr und auch beim
zehnten Mal im friedlichen niedlichen
Münster wird es muss es ums Überleben
der Ukraine gehen es ist kein leichter
Tag zum Demonstrieren aber was ist schon
leicht wenn der Ehemann der Sohn der
Bruder ums eigene Land kämpft ums eigene
Leben gerade wenn man denke schlimmer
könne es nicht gehen sagt die G7
Gastgeberin versinke russlands Präsident
noch tiefer in Unmenschlichkeit
indem er versucht die Menschen
verhungern verdursten und erfrieren zu
lassen indem er gezielt zivile
Infrastruktur angreift und genau das
werden wir als G7 Partner mit allem was
wir haben versuchen zu verhindern
wow in den Friedenssaal des historischen
Rathauses bittet bärbock eine G7 Runde
wie es sie noch nie gab zum ersten Mal
ist Außenminister Tajani dabei von der
neuen rechtsradikalen Regierung Italiens
zum ersten Mal ist Außenminister
cleverly dabei von der neuen
EU-kritischen Regierung Großbritanniens
aber über die jetzt nötige Winterhilfe
ist sich die Gruppe der sieben
uneingeschränkt einig genug
vor allem werden wir die Produkte
liefern die am dringendsten gebraucht
werden Generatoren Pumpen Heizgeräte und
Ersatzteile
die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen in Münster sind
streng der Herbstwind stark es ist kein
leichter Tag zum Demonstrieren aber ein
guter um es zu versuchen auch
Außenministerin baerbock nutzt die große
Bühne um eine Botschaft zu platzieren
sie gilt ihren Gästen aber mehr noch dem
Bundeskanzler der Morgen in China
erwartet wird wir werden mit Blick auf
die Entwicklung in China gemeinsam
darüber sprechen wie wir Fehler der
Vergangenheit die wir in der
russland-politik hatten nicht erneut
wiederholen es ist kein Geheimnis das
sechs der G7 das vor allem die USA
Deutschlands China Politik kritisch bis
sehr kritisch sehen ein Thema fürs Abend
essen wenn die Türen zu und die Handys
aus sind die Außenminister dürften
keiner Demonstranten gesehen haben es
war kein leichter Tag aber sie waren da
die Krisen der Welt also in zwei Tagen
Spitzen treffen das tun sich ja wirklich
überall Herausforderungen auf von
globalem Ausmaß guten Abend dann
Außenministerin Annalena beerburg
schönen guten Abend Frau bärburg lassen
Sie uns über drei Brennpunkte vielleicht
reden zunächst die Ukraine da haben sie
jetzt eine Winterhilfe verabredet was
ist das konkret außer zunächst mal ein
Schlagwort
das heißt konkret viele Generatoren weil
wir erleben müssen wie sie im Beitrag ja
deutlich gemacht haben dass der
russische Präsident immer dann wenn man
denkt schlimmer kann es nicht mehr
werden noch mehr Brutalität kann es gar
nicht geben noch eine weitere Stufe der
Unmenschlichkeit betritt und in den
Städten wo er offensichtlich militärisch
keinen Erfolg hat wählt er jetzt eine
Strategie wo die Menschen im Winter
drohen zu erfrieren oder im Zweifel zu
verdursten oder zu verhungern weil die
Angriffe auf die Energieversorgung auf
Stromnetze bedeuten zum Beispiel dass
Pumpen die Wasserpumpen können nicht
mehr laufen können und deswegen schicken
wir mobile Generatoren in die Ukraine es
braucht aber sehr sehr großes Gerät es
braucht Häuser bzw Container wo Kinder
im Winter auch überhaupt noch lernen
können und das gemeinsam jetzt als
g7-partner zu koordinieren darum geht es
hier mit unserem winterhilfepaket und
wir haben in den letzten Monaten erlebt
wenn wir als stärkste demokratische
Industriestaaten uns zusammentun dann
können wir nicht nur große
sanktionspakete auf dem Weg bringen
militärische Unterstützung zur
Selbstverteidigung sondern dann können
wir in der Brutalität dieses Krieges
auch ein Stück Zivilisation und
humanitäre Hilfe leisten und das werden
wir für den Winter jetzt gemeinsam tun
dann ein wichtiges Thema heute der Iran
im Iran ruft das Auswärtige Amt ihr
Auswärtiges Amt jetzt alle deutschen auf
auszureisen ist das auch ein politisches
Zeichen dass sie damit setzen wollen
das ist vor allen Dingen eine
Sicherheitsvorkehrung ich bin als
Außenministerin ja auch dafür
verantwortlich dass diejenigen die
deutsche Staatsbürgerinnen und
Staatsbürger sind und in Situationen
sich befinden wo ihre eigenes Leben
möglicherweise in Gefahr ist dass wir da
entsprechende Warnung herausgeben und
deswegen haben wir diesen Schritt jetzt
gewählt auch diesen Schritt gemeinsam
mit unseren internationalen Partnern und
rufen dazu auf dass deutsche
Staatsangehörige aus dem Iran ausreißen
wie groß ist die Gefahr für deutsche im
Iran aktuell
wir sehen mit welcher furchtbaren Gewalt
das iranische Regime gegen seine eigene
Bevölkerung vorgeht wir haben erlebt
dass die Morde an unschuldigen Frauen an
Jugendlichen an halb erwachsenen
Menschen da Menschen die einfach nur für
ihr Recht auf ein freies Leben auf die
Straße gehen dass auf diese Menschen
willkürlich eingeprügelt wird dass
Menschen verschleppt werden dass Frauen
vergewaltigte werden und deswegen die
Lage ist hochdramatisch das erleben wir
leider jeden Tag und so wie wir die
Menschen im Iran unterstützen die jetzt
so mutig auf die Straße gehen so ist es
auch meine Verantwortung für deutsche
Staatsangehörige die zurückkehren können
Sie eindringlich zu bitten nach
Deutschland zurückzukehren dann reden
wir Frau Werbung über China wir haben
sie gerade im Beitrag gehört sie haben
wir heute gesagt da dürfen wir die
Fehler der Vergangenheit die wir in der
russland-politik hatten nicht
wiederholen jetzt ist der Bundeskanzler
gerade eben im Moment auf dem Weg nach
China hatten ihm abgeraten von so einer
Reise jetzt wiederholt er gerade Fehler
der Vergangenheit
der Bundeskanzler reist nach China um
dort gemeinsam deutlich zu machen dass
wir logischerweise die globalen
Herausforderungen wie die Klimakrise nur
gemeinsam lösen können dass wir bei der
Pandemie besser gefahren werden wenn wir
von Anfang an weltweit gemeinsam
zusammengearbeitet hätten dass wir aber
eben auch aus unserer fatalen
Abhängigkeit von Russland für uns unsere
Lehren gezogen haben deswegen eine
china-strategie schreiben darüber
sprechen wir hier auch beim G7
Außenministerin treffen und in dieser
china-strategie deutlich machen dass wir
uns zukünftig nicht noch mal so abhängig
machen von anderen Ländern die unsere
Werte nicht teilen dass wir dann
handlungsfähig sprechen sie haben sie
haben vor ein paar Tagen das wird die
Botschaft des Kanzlers sein da waren sie
vor ein paar Tagen noch nicht ganz so
überzeugt haben ihm auch noch mal
geraten doch darauf hinzuweisen dass
China auch Rivale ist und nicht nur
Partner jetzt scheint das nicht ganz so
gut angekommen zu sein im
Bundeskanzleramt der SPD-Fraktionschef
rol wusste nicht wird heute so zitiert
der Kanzler benötige keine Ratschläge
auch nicht von der eigenen
Außenministerin deren Einlassungen aus
dem Ausland unhöflich und
undiszipliniert waren ziehen sie sich
den Schuh an
nein weil ich deutlich gemacht habe dass
wir gemeinsam im Koalitionsvertrag eine
china-strategie vereinbart haben ich
weiß dass das übertitelt wurde ist auch
von Reisetipps oder anderen Sachen ich
habe deutlich gemacht dass mit der
Botschaft die wir gemeinsam beschlossen
haben dass wir eben mit Blick auf China
sehen müssen dass China sich massiv
verändert hat und das hat dieser letzte
Parteikongress ja noch mal deutlich
gemacht der japanische Kollege hatte
gerade hier auch bei unser Sitzung noch
mal aufgezeigt welche Vertreter in dem
engsten Kreis des chinesischen
Präsidenten sind dass sich eben die
politische Haltung verändert hat und
deswegen habe ich in Zentralasien gesagt
dass unsere Botschaft in Zentralasien
ist wir bieten euch Partnerschaften auf
Augenhöhe und dass das auch die
Botschaft des Bundeskanzlers in China
sein wird dass wir uns diversifizieren
das heißt mit anderen Länder in Ländern
stärker zusammenarbeiten insbesondere
rohstoffebereich woher Mütze ich habe
jetzt noch nicht äh das weiß ich nicht
so ganz ich habe auch noch nicht ganz
verstanden was sie jetzt konkret vom
Bundeskanzler erwarten also reicht es
diesmal dass er wie früher immer mit
einer großen Wirtschaftsdelegation kommt
die ist ja auch diesmal wieder dabei und
dann einfach hinter verschlossenen Türen
mal kurz die Menschenrechte anspricht
also ich habe bereits eben deutlich
gemacht und habe das auch in den
vergangenen Tagen gesagt dass wir als
Bundesregierung gemeinsam eine China
Strategie fahren alles andere macht ja
überhaupt gar kein Sinn und so wie ich
das in Zentralasien deutlich gesagt habe
wird das auch der Bundeskanzler sagen
das hat er selber vor seiner Abfahrt
auch mehrfach gesagt dass er die
Menschenrechte ansprechen wird dass er
über die Frage von fairen
Wettbewerbsbedingungen reden wird und
das sind keine Ratschläge sondern dass
es das auf was wir uns gemeinsam als
Bundesregierung verständigt haben
Annalena baerbock die
bundesaußenministerin live aus Münster
herzlichen Dank
danke ebenso alles Gute Ihnen auch danke
während der Kanzler also im Flugzeug
sitzt Richtung Peking gucken wir jetzt
was dieser Besuch aus chinesischer Sicht
ist neben den Tatsachen dass er als
erster westlicher Regierungschef kommt
seit Beginn der Pandemie und der erste
aus dem Westen kurz nachdem sich Chinas
Machthaber gerade zum uneingeschränkten
Herrscher wählen ließ aus Peking jetzt
Miriam Steiner
Schindlers Tankstelle so heißt das
typisch deutsche Wirtshaus mitten in
Peking vor dem Besuch des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers gibt's hier ganz
praktische Fragen
nach China kommt muss er dann eigentlich
auch Quarantäne machen
mindestens 7 Tage staatliche Quarantäne
für alle die aus dem Ausland kommen das
ist die Regel für wichtige Staatsgäste
wie Scholz gilt die nicht dafür muss
dann die chinesische Seite in Quarantäne
wenn er wieder weg ist Treffen mit
Kritikern des chinesischen Staates macht
das nahezu unmöglich denn auch die
müssten danach in Quarantäne unter
staatlicher Kontrolle
es ist ein Besuch nach Chinas
Spielregeln Scholz ist der erste
westliche Staatschef der kommt nach dem
hidden-ping den ein Parteienstaat beim
Parteitag endgültig in eine ein
mann-diktatur umgebaut hat die
chinesische Propaganda freut sich über
Scholz Gastgeschenk über den cosco-deal
mit dem Hamburger Hafen
die europäische wertede Debatte die
europäische systemrivalitätsdebatte wird
als eine ideologische bezeichnet und
Scholz wird in der chinesischen
Regierung wahrgenommen als jemand der
weniger ideologisch ist und China
gegenüber eher positiv
China braucht Deutschland als
verlässlichen Partner in der EU es will
Geschäfte machen nicht über
Menschenrechte sprechen
die Zusammenarbeit in den vergangenen 50
Jahren hat bewiesen dass beide Länder
mehr Übereinstimmungen als Differenzen
haben die Zusammenarbeit überragt den
Wettbewerb bei weitem wir sind Partner
nicht Rivalen
und die Erwartungshaltung einer der
schon sehr viele Staatsbesuche in China
miterlebt hat ist Jörg Wuttke
Vorsitzender der eu-handelskammer wir
waren wieder mit ihm in seinem Büro
verabredet doch wie viele Millionen
Menschen gerade darf er seine Wohnung
nicht verlassen es ist diese Willkür der
Null corvette-politik die Gänge nicht
nur die Menschen sondern sorgt auch für
schlechte Wirtschaftszahlen Europa soll
einspringen
an Europa ist wahnsinnig wichtig
verschiedene als technologiegeber aber
auch als Markt und Deutschland ist
natürlich die große wirtschaftsnummer
dort die Hälfte aller
import-exporter aus China gehen nach
Deutschland Deutschland ist ein
wichtiger Investitionsort jetzt nicht
nur für kosko sondern auch für
Batteriehersteller neben deutschen
Fußballprofis nennen die Chinesinnen und
Chinesen im Pekinger Wirtshaus immer
wieder einen Namen wenn es um
Deutschland geht
egal welche Partei oder wer Deutschland
regiert sie sollen von Merkel lernen sie
hat meinen vollsten Respekt aus ganzem
Herzen als sie neu war habe ich es nicht
gleich kapiert aber die Frau ist stark
so gute Wirtschaftsbeziehungen wie mit
Merkel das wünscht sich die chinesische
Führung vor dem Antrittsbesuch des neuen
Kanzlers
unser nächstes Thema sie erleben es
vermutlich gerade selbst Deutschland
diskutiert und zwar heftig über die
aktuelle
radikalere Protestwelle von
klimaaktivisten die sehen sich als
letzte Generation sie kleben sich an
Gemälden und auf Straßenfest ein Ziel
haben sie damit erreicht größtmögliche
Aufmerksamkeit allerdings redet kaum
noch jemand über die Hintergründe des
Protests und alle über die Form und das
liegt am tragischen Fall einer
Radfahrerin bei der jetzt der Hirntod
festgestellt wurde nachdem sie in Berlin
von einem LKW überrollt worden war und
die Feuerwehr im Stau stand auch weil
klimaaktivisten die Straße sperrten der
Protest gegen den Protest nimmt zu
Christian von Rechenberg
das ZDF-Interview ist gerade zu Ende da
erreicht die Sprecherin der sogenannten
letzten Generation die Nachricht vom
Hirntod der verunglückten Radfahrerin
wir tun alles um die Sicherheit jeder
Teilnehmer in dort zu gewährleisten wir
lassen immer ausnahmslos eine
Rettungsgasse und ich kann auch noch mal
betonen dass wir nicht leichtfertig in
diesem Protest gehen das mag stimmen
doch in den sozialen Medien tobt die Wut
die eine nehmen die Blockierer von
Berlin in Schutz die anderen beschimpfen
sie als Terroristen und Mörder die
Solidarität der Bevölkerung mit den
blockieren bröckelt
das ist ja schon der letzten Zeit
beobachtbar gewesen dass diese
Straßenblockaden extrem viel Gegenwehr
provozieren das ist auch naja
skandalisierungsversuche von
verschiedenen Medien von politischen
Parteien auch gab obwohl die
Straßenblockade an sich eigentlich
erstmal ein legitimes und auch
historisch weit zurückreichen das sind
noch etabliertes Mittel des Protests in
der Demokratie ist
aber ist sowas noch legitim Angriffe auf
Kunstwerke
Farbe auf Parteizentralen und
Straßenblockaden als Dauerzustand diese
Taktik mag grenzwertig sein sagt der
Experte bliebe aber im Rahmen
das sind aber alles noch Form des
Protests die sich explizit und auch
prinzipiell von der Gewalt gegen
Menschen abgrenzen und darauf aus
prinzipiellen Gründen verzichten in
dieser Hinsicht ist der Protest nicht
sehr radikal oder militant noch nicht
was ich ändern könnte wenn das
Klimaproblem noch drängender noch
greifbarer wird noch sagt die Gruppe
wolle sie nur Reibung erzeugen die
Diskussion provozieren ich glaube dass
viele sich in dem Moment anfangen
Gedanken darüber zu machen was legitim
ist und was nicht und vor allem auch wo
unsere Aktionsbereitschaft überhaupt
herkommt die kommt ja aus einem Platz
der Verzweiflung die kommt aus einem ja
einer großen Angst aber sind sie
wirklich die letzte Generation die noch
was ändern kann ändern muss bevor die
Klimakatastrophe unaufhaltsam ist ganz
falsch sei das nicht sagen
Wissenschaftler aber deswegen dürfen man
nicht den Kopf verlieren
die Art und Weise wie es jetzt bei der
letzten Generation geschieht durch sehr
viele Menschen ab und wir werden
tatsächlich einen ambitionierten
Klimaschutz nur hinbekommen wenn wir
breite Schichten der Bevölkerung dafür
gewinnen was zurückführt zur Diskussion
um den Unfall in Berlin die eines nicht
vergessen darf es gilt die
Unschuldsvermutung solange es kein
Urteil gibt
ja für die juristische Seite des Ganzen
ist unsere Rechtsexpertin bei uns Sarah
Tacke hallo Sarah hallo bleiben wir
vielleicht erstmal bei dem tragischen
Fall der Radfahrerin bei dem die
Feuerwehr im Stau stand das tut sie ja
leider häufiger mal parkt jemand in
zweiter Reihe mal gibt es keine
Rettungsgasse wie sehr sind sind die
stauferursacher dafür verantwortlich im
juristischen Sinne wenn die Feuerwehr da
nicht helfen kann also ganz klar ist
egal ob nun durch parken in zweiter
Reihe oder durchs gaffen oder eben durch
so eine Blockade sobald Rettungskräfte
behindert werden und derjenige der sie
behindert das auch billigend in Kauf
nimmt ist er strafbar denn die
Behinderung von Rettungskräften ist eine
Straftat sehr viel schwieriger ist es zu
beantworten juristisch ob jemand der
eine Straße blockiert am Ende auch wegen
fahrlässiger Körperverletzung oder
fahrlässiger Tötung haftbar gemacht
werden kann und da kommt es immer auf
die Kausalität an also ganz konkret in
diesem Fall die Frage wäre die Radfahrer
noch am Leben hätte es diese Blockade
nicht gegeben und nur wenn man das mit
an Sicherheit grenzender
Wahrscheinlichkeit mit Ja beantworten
kann nur dann kann man im Zweifel auch
jemanden wegen fahrlässiger tüftung
gehabtbar machen in den allermeisten
Fällen wird aber genau dieser Beweis
sehr schwer zu führen sein und dann
heißt es immer in dubioporio im Zweifel
für den Angeklagten wäre in diesem Fall
wahrscheinlich auch sehr schwierig
schauen wir doch mal generell auf diese
neuen Protestaktionen die Aktivisten
argumentieren ja quasi so nach dem Motto
der Zweck heiligt die Mittel ist das
eine Argumentation die juristisch zieht
absolut nicht egal ob im Namen des
Klimaschutzes oder der Weltrettung all
das rechtfertig keine Straftaten im
Gegenteil also man kann nicht sagen man
man protestiert und das seine notwende
notwehr ist nur wenn ich wirklich
angegriffen werde beispielsweise mit
einem Messer dann darf ich zum
Gegenschlag ausholen aber die
Erderwärmung ist eben kein Messerangriff
im juristischen Sinne deshalb ganz klar
der Zweck heiligt nicht die Mittel was
hat denn der Staat in der Hand gegen
diese Proteste greift er aktuell durch
oder lässt er eher gewähren der Staat
hat das Strafgesetzbuch in der Hand
nicht wenig aber eben auch nicht mehr
heißt ganz konkret wenn Bild beschädigt
wird strafbare Sachbeschädigung wenn
eine Strafe blockiert wird
ist es im Zweifel eine strafbare
Nötigung aber man darf nicht weil es
jetzt politisch erwartet wird oder weil
der öffentliche Druck groß ist an
klimaaktivisten Exempel statuieren in
jedem Einzelfall muss die individuelle
Schuld der Protestierenden beurteilt
werden und man darf nicht sagen zur
Abschreckung bestrafen wir sie jetzt
besonders hart das geht nicht
interessante und sehr klare Analyse wie
immer Sarah herzlichen Dank dafür Danke
und im heute schon mal Update Fragen von
Nazan gökdemir an die klimaaktivistin
Luisa Neubauer von Fridays for future
jetzt hier bei uns aber erstmal
einen Tag nach dem bund-länder-gipfel
zur Energiekrise gibt es Kritik an den
beschlossenen Entlastungen zum Beispiel
dass die gaspreisbremse zu spät komme
die Kommunen fordern zudem mehr Geld für
die Flüchtlingshilfe teilweise
umstritten ist auch das 49 euro-ticket
das Sozialverbände und die Linke als zu
teuer kritisieren der Verband Deutscher
Verkehrsunternehmen hält außerdem den
für Januar geplanten Start des
Monatstickets für nicht machbar
der Verfassungsschutz darf nicht mehr so
viele heimlich gesammelte persönliche
Daten an Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaften weitergeben die
bisherigen übermittlungsbefugnisse seien
zu weitgehend und verschließen gegen das
Grundrecht auf informationelle
Selbstbestimmung entschied heute das
Bundesverfassungsgericht bis Ende 2023
muss die Daten Weitergabe neu geregelt
werden bis dahin gelten Einschränkungen
geklagt hatte ein es ein verurteilter
nsu-helfer
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
hat bei ihren Untersuchungen von drei
ukrainischen Standorten bisher nach
eigenen Angaben keine Hinweise auf den
Bau einer sogenannten schmutzigen Bombe
gefunden russland hatte der Ukraine
vorgeworfen an einer solchen mit
nuklearen Material bestückten Bombe zu
arbeiten Kiew hatte dies zurückgewiesen
beim
westbalkan-gipfel in Berlin hat sich
Bundeskanzler Scholz dafür ausgesprochen
dass die sechs Länder so schnell wie
möglich der EU beitreten sollten einen
festen Zeitplan gebe es jedoch nicht
erklärte kommissionspräsidentin von der
Leyen und verwies auf nötige Reformen
Serbien nordmazedonien
Bosnien-Herzegowina Kosovo Montenegro
und Albanien unterzeichneten mehrere
Abkommen die sie unter anderem
verpflichten gegenseitig ihre
Personalausweise und Berufsabschlüsse
anzuerkennen
und jetzt in der Sendung ein bisschen
Hoffnung dass ein Krieg endet von dem
die Welt außerhalb Afrikas kaum Notizen
nimmt obwohl er nach Schätzungen bereits
eine halbe Million Tote gefordert hat im
Norden von Äthiopien bekämpfen sich
Rebellen und Regierungstruppen seit zwei
Jahren gnadenlos um den Vielvölkerstaat
zusammenzuhalten begann die Regierung in
Addis Abeba eine Offensive der Armee die
T3 Rebellen halten dagegen brutale
Menschenrechtsverletzungen auf beiden
Seiten Hunger als Waffe jetzt aber gibt
es Grund zur Hoffnung dass das Morden
aufhört Waffenruhe Friedensgespräche und
vielleicht wirklich das Ende eines
Krieges Sandra Theis berichtet
es ist ein Handschlag der Hoffnung macht
nach tagelang Verhandlungen in Südafrika
haben sich die Regierung Äthiopiens und
die volksbefreiungsfront von Tigra auf
einen Waffenstillstand geeinigt
vermittelt durch die Afrikanische Union
beide Parteien in dem äthiopischen
Konflikt haben sich formell auf eine
Einstellung der Feindseligkeiten
geeinigt
sowie auf eine systematische ordentliche
und koordinierte Abrüstung
die
äthiopische Regierung nennt es einen
Meilenstein
jetzt geht es darum die durch den
Konflikt zerstörten Orte wieder
aufzubauen das Ausmaß der Zerstörung ist
immens die Dunkelheit massiv wir danken
unseren Brüdern der Gegenseite für ihr
konstruktives Engagement um dem Land zu
erlauben die tragische Periode des
Konfliktes hinter sich zu lassen
Rückblick im November 2020 war
Äthiopiens premier Abi Ahmed gegen die
tiegreiher in den Krieg gezogen die
volksbefreiungsfront von Tigray hatte
selbst jahrelang Äthiopiens Politik
beherrscht und weigerte sich Abi als
Regierungschef anzuerkennen in den
blutigen Kämpfen die damals begannen
starben schätzungen zufolge mehr als
500.000 Menschen Millionen wurden
vertrieben beiden Seiten werden
Gräueltaten und Kriegsverbrechen
vorgeworfen
die äthiopische Regierung setzte auch
Hunger als Waffe ein blockierte die
Region Tigray ließ Hilfslieferung nicht
zu
das Abkommen soll unter anderem auch
Hilfslieferungen wieder möglich machen
ein wichtiger Punkt für die tieg-reiher
unsere Leute starben nicht nur durch
Kugeln sondern auch durch den Mangel an
Nahrung und Medikamenten
unsere Kinder gehen nicht in die Schule
unsere Krankenhäuser können wegen des
Krieges nicht arbeiten wir haben immer
gefühlt dass dieser Krieg uns
aufgezwungen wurde und wir waren immer
bereit alles in unserer Macht stehende
zu tun um diesen Krieg zu beenden
bislang existiert der Frieden nur auf
dem Papier Oper Realität wird bleibt
abzuwarten Grund zur Skepsis gibt es
allemal so war Eritrea das auf der Seite
Äthiopiens kämpft gar nicht an den
Friedensverhandlungen beteiligt und doch
ist das Abkommen mein erster Schritt der
vielleicht für Millionen von Zivilisten
in Äthiopien die Lage verbessert
unsere Skepsis aber eben auch Grund zur
Hoffnung jetzt unfassbare Zahlen bei dir
Hanna ja das kann man so sagen es geht
um ein gigantisches Minus von 40
Milliarden Euro so hoch ist der Verlust
des taumelnden gaskonzerns Juniper in
den ersten neun Monaten dieses Jahres
Frank Bethmann das Unternehmen steht ja
kurz vor der Verstaatlichung ist Juniper
dann überhaupt noch zu retten alleine
schwerlich deswegen steht Juniper ja
auch kurz vor eben jener Verstaatlichung
insgesamt kann das Management und später
der Bund als Eigentümer nur darauf
hoffen dass die Gaspreise weiter wie
zuletzt zurückgehen das würde schon eine
erhebliche Entlastung bedeuten denn seit
Monaten häufte der importeurverluste von
teilweise über 100 Millionen Euro
täglich an Gas das Juniper aus Russland
nicht mehr bekam musste anderen Ort für
horrendes Geld eingekauft werden damit
die Versorgung in Deutschland nicht
zusammenbricht der Verkauf der
russischen Tochter juni pro könnte einen
Teil zur Sanierung beitragen betreibt in
Russland einige Gas und Kernkraftwerke
will diese veräußern was im Augenblick
aber schwierig sein zu Jahresbeginn noch
unvorstellbar an der Börse verliert die
Aktie seit Kriegsausbruch 91 Prozent an
Wert Juniper der gasgroßhändler der sich
zu stark auf Lieferungen aus Russland
ausgerichtet hat wird Opfer seiner
verfehlten Konzernstrategie da das
Düsseldorfer Unternehmen aber eine
zentrale Rolle für die Erdgasversorgung
in Deutschland einnimmt betreibt bleibt
die bunt praktisch keine andere Wahl als
in die Bresche zu springen trüber Tag
auch für den DAX heute das
Aktienbarometer verliert 127 Punkte oder
ein knappes Prozent danke Frank für
deine Einschätzung
zum Sport und der Fußball Europa League
da hat der SC Freiburg im abschließenden
Gruppenspiel gegen Karabach eins zu eins
unentschieden gespielt Freiburg stand
allerdings schon zuvor als Gruppensieger
und achtelfinalist fest
die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katha
findet ohne Nationalspieler Timo Werner
statt der Stürmer von RB Leipzig zog
sich gestern im Champions-League-Spiel
gegen Donezk eine Verletzung im linken
Sprunggelenk zu und fällt bis Jahresende
aus
Bundestrainer Flick sprach von einem
herben Verlust
wir haben ja zu Beginn der Sendung schon
mit der Außenministerin gesprochen über
die Lage im Iran Deutschland ruft seine
Staatsbürger auf Iran zu verlassen es
lohnt sich genauer hin zu sehen was da
gerade passiert und das tun wir gleich
nach uns hier im ZDF ausführlich in
einem zdf-spezial Aufstand gegen die
Mullahs der Kampf gegen das Regime in
Iran das ist ein Film ein sehenswerter
unseres Iran Korrespondenten Jörg Brase
Maybrit Illner kommt direkt danach und
wir alle hier sagen tschüss und wünschen
Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der europäische
Kontinent heizt sich am schnellsten auf
so die weltmeteologie Organisation und
das spüren wir auch in Deutschland der
vergangene Oktober war extrem und ist
jetzt genauso warm mit 2001 es sind die
wärmsten oktobermonate in unserer
Zeitreihe die wir hier auch und auf
unserer Grafik erkennen können und die
Tendenz die ist klar die Temperaturen
steigen immer weiter an sind es hier an
der schwarzen Linie die immer weiter
ansteigt schauen wir auf das Wetter da
gibt es kühle Luft aus dem Nordwesten
und Regen der uns überquert Schnee ist
auch mit dabei und zwar im Alpenrand
oberkolden 1200 Metern gibt es 20 bis 30
cm Schnee ja und der Regen der verlagert
sich allmählich ostwärts ganz im Osten
ist es aber noch trocken bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 4 Grad an den Alpen und
10 bis 11 Grad im Nordwesten morgen dann
weiterer Regen der sich aber allmählich
nach Osten verlagert und dann abzieht im
Südwesten gibt es weitere shower genauso
wie Richtung Emsland und
Schleswig-Holstein über der Nordsee
teils Sturmböen aus westlichen
Richtungen Temperaturen dazu Höchstwerte
14 Grad
im Westen und sieben Grad ganz im Süden
die nächsten Tage gibt es noch Schauer
es wird aber weniger die Sonne zeigt
sich häufiger 6 bis 13 am Samstag und
Montag bis zu 17 Grad ein schönen Abend